you know what's interesting about all of
this Ai and Instagram and the age that
we're living in do you sometimes think
that there was a spiritual advantage to
the time that you were in talking about
oh my God I say it all the time
for the 70s yeah
um
it was a crazy time no no seven is
wasn't really turbulent and in a more in
a way that we we consume retrospect it
was more generative than we realized at
the time we thought we were just taking
a rest after the 60s
um but it was like any period of rest
generating the next thing
um
there is no doubt about it I you know I
used to say that I learned most of what
I know on airplanes because I would find
it so fascinating talking to people next
to me on airplanes if somebody doesn't
know you so doesn't have any
preconceived ideas about you everybody's
a little more aware than usual of their
mortality and you really meet all kinds
of people you would never meet under
other circumstances today you get on a
plane and more often than not people
want to close their their drape at their
window they want to close the shade so
that the most magnificent drama of
nature is not available to them for
whatever reason in order to watch a
Grade B movie or get on their tablet or
put on their their earphones immediately
and there's a human being next to them
there's nothing well the entire mystery
of the cosmos is next to them right yes
exactly exactly I remember one man who I
once said hi I'm Marianne he went good
he couldn't even bring himself to say hi
I'm Mark some man I know he said
lin-manuel I'm like well Miranda
no I totally know what you mean I I
think there's a metaphor there in fact
I'm working on a movie and one of the
symbols is how we're always blocking our
ears we're always putting on we don't
and then we say well where's love I
can't find love the course of Miracle
says you're like people in a very bright
room with your uh fingers in front of
your eyes going it's it's dark in here
yeah I mean we miss out on so much
because we miss the person and that's
why it it concerns me when I see these
little children on tablets right so talk
about quiet and talk about mind
searching and talk about the decision
maker which I you know that term isn't
in the course but Ken talks about the
decision maker Ken wapnick oh yeah the
idea that it's all of this the the two
lessons
yesterday's lesson was my my salvation
comes from me yeah that one forget it
I'm struck with how many times Jesus in
the course is saying the whole thing in
one lesson and my salvation comes from
me was one of those lessons right where
I'll never also love made me like itself
is this is what I mean created me like
itself right and hope created me hopeful
and Faith created me faithful and peace
created me peaceful wholeness created me
holy I have the chills I can't say it
and you know it you know there's a pure
place in you that is all of those things
and this is what I'm putting back to you
and I'm go you know I was just on an
airplane watching a movie yesterday so
I'm not doing it all I'm not saying we
shouldn't watch movies
I'm not there all the time but like I
part of the flight I was there part of
the flight I would close my eyes did my
lesson and I was like oh my God I was
right there so forget the 70s Shepherds
with their shape or you know what I'm
saying like throughout human history we
had more time to spelunk into our inner
reality no we didn't no we didn't have
more time they just have fewer
distractions that's why you know every
religious system or spiritual system
that I've ever read about emphasizes the
power of the morning if you wake up in
the morning and the first thing you do
is you go to Snapchat or Instagram or
your social media or you download the
newspaper You are downloading the
stressful perspective of the world and
it's very difficult to change later
that's why the Course in Miracles talks
about doing the exercises in the morning
all the great religious systems do if
you take the time and the course of
Miracles does say five minutes went with
the Holy Spirit in the morning is enough
to guarantee he will be in charge of
your thought forms throughout the day if
you do your exercise in the morning you
will have a different nervous system
yeah and if you instead allow your
nervous system to become wrinkled by all
the meaningless thoughts of the world
good luck on not being depressed by noon
right and then of course uh unregulated
capitalism has come up with an answer
for that of course isn't it I mean you
just said a mouthful but isn't it
interesting I think we sort of get
addicted to fear it becomes like oh it
is yes it is yes absolutely well why do
we run to it or sometimes well it of
course says you want to be angry if
you're angry you want to be well it's
your own mind turned against you right
the mind is so powerful being literally
of the mind of God whatever thought you
think has power
so you were totally at Choice what
thought to think but something you don't
have a choice about is whether or not
your thinking will be powerful so all
thought the course says takes you and
those around you straight to heaven or
straight to hell heaven is not a
condition or a place it's an awareness
of our Oneness hell is not a condition
or a place it's the anxiety that the ego
would have you feel in any moment that
you feel separate from the rest of life
that's how powerful thoughts are and the
course of Miracle says there's no such
thing as a neutral thought that goes
back to what we're saying before about
discipline you know you go to the
physical gym you work out because you're
you're honing your physical muscles so
that you can move and be strong with
spiritual exercise you're honing your
attitudinal muscles so you can be
non-reactive and still like the line be
still and know because if I'm not still
I can't know only in Stillness can I get
clarity right so it's it's very parallel
to the physical world and the physical
world there's gravity and as I grow
older if I'm not countering gravity
accumulated weight-bearing Etc my
muscles headed down emotional gravity
psychological gravity if I'm not
repeating accumulated
repetitions of high-minded thoughts I'm
being pulled down by cynicism I'm being
pulled down by negativity I'm being
pulled down by victim Consciousness I'm
being pulled down by anger I'm being
pulled down that that's what emotional
and psychological and spiritual gravity
is so we do spiritual exercise much like
we do physical exercise to hone our
musculature you have an emotional body
just like you have a physical body and
you can have the healthiest physical
body in the world but if you go into a
meeting a business meeting or any person
any relationship and you bring with you
your negativity your cynicism your
nihilism your control people are going I
don't want that
um
it's interesting going back tying what
the lesson was into what you just said
uh Salvation comes from me it's
interesting my my choice of thinking
right and every moment the course of
Miracle says you're making that choice
you make it consciously or you make it
unconsciously but every moment we're
making a choice but and that's power so
starting the day remind remembering that
what you're thinking and your mind
stayed and what you're being drawn to
and what you're listening to inside
right so when you replace it with
someone else's worldview whether it be
ads for things to buy right that's
another thing it's isn't that salvation
I I I'll admit that I've when I was a
young man I'd order an iPad and I
remember vividly going I can't die that
iPad is coming like like the iPad was
gonna save me and so that doesn't work
and you outgrew that and yes I did
outgrow that but also the ego you know
says I just saw my name on a marquee
last night and I took a moment to go
like this isn't it this won't say well
good good for you Peter virtue sampling
but I'm just saying like isn't that the
point like we think if we're famous we
think if we're rich we think you know I
talked to a friend of mine the other day
and he was his book and you know it's a
big major bestseller and he said no I'm
identifying it with it too much I said
oh give me a break give your chances you
can celebrate for a couple days you know
we don't want to spiritually bypass it
wasn't well that would even be bypassing
something negative is usually when you
think of spiritual bypassing let's not
bypass something positive there is such
thing as righteous Commerce there is
such thing as righteous uh celebration
it's when you take it Beyond any level
of appropriate uh perspective that
there's a problem but I think it's cool
the first time you see your name on a
marquee you go cool sure this would have
been the 500 so I'm starting to get over
it yeah I don't take it too far well
it's interesting it's it's what are we
talking about when we talk about
salvation like well the only thing to be
safe from is your own insane thinking
right that's the course of Miracles the
only thing to be saved from is the
thought system of fear and separation
that dominates this world yeah I I
absolutely love that so if my name on
the Marquee leads to the thought will I
be here next year or will the show sell
out that's not helpful if I go I did a
show I did a good job but I can't it's
like Maya Angelou said you can't pick it
up you can't lay it down right I can't
live and die by whether or not the show
went well right well the ego will always
take you to whatever thought if you're
successful the ego once says yeah but
you might not be successful tomorrow the
ego will take whatever the circumstance
is and interpret it in such a way is to
make you feel bad right because your
pain is the ego's peak experience and
you know and Freud's yeah
Freud said that that intelligence will
be used in the service of the Neurosis
so the ego will just say whatever it is
to make you unable to just enjoy the
moment says then you worry about losing
the house and I see it well exactly the
thing is if the course of Miracle says
that the Holy Spirit your salvation lies
in a different sense of purpose so your
different sense of purpose is
um I am here uh at this theater to do a
comedy show and my hope is that my
talents and my expertise will be used in
such a way to uplift people and give
them some happiness while they're here
so the more you are proactively in the
light about it the darkness cannot enter
[Music]
oh yeah